the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
so last week Melissa told you
couple days ago about vision and if
there's two huge messages I think out of
that lecture its first that even the
most simple aspects of perception are
based on a synthesis between what's out
there and the rules by which your mind
interprets the world and what you
ultimately see is that interaction that
synthesis that dialogue the construction
between what's out there
and how your mind chooses to interpret
it the second big point is that there's
a lot of organization of the visual
system in our brain and we can track its
organization from the first moment that
photons enter your eyes all the way
through until you recognize a loved one
a word or an object out there and and
then we said that in the neocortex the
world is divided into two big channels
of visual processing which are what
things are and where things are right
okay so now I'm going to pick up on that
a little bit today as you go around and
see things all the time
what is it that you mostly see at an
average day you wake up in the morning I
know you know what's you're looking for
what's the answer but it isn't
everything you see people write a lot so
faces we'll talk about that you see
objects chairs tables in the morning a
toothbrush and soap is useful right
you see objects and another huge use of
your visual system is reading you see
words right on books on computers so
we're gonna talk about a little bit
about how we see what things are objects
in the world faces in the world and
words so that we can read and we'll talk
about both how we some some processes
that go on and our mind and brain that
let us become terrific at recognizing
what's out there and and and knowing who
we're talking to what we're reading what
we're holding and so on and then about
disorders in the brain that illuminate I
think a little bit about those processes
so let me start with objects and and
agnosia agnosia means not knowing so
we're gonna talk about two
in which people have seemed to not know
and that gives us a hint in about how we
actually do know and they've been called
a perceptive and associative ignacio's a
perceptive seems to be people see the
parts but they don't pull it together
associated Ignacio they see the whole
thing pretty decently but they can't
figure out what it means what it is in
the practical sense and lastly I'll talk
to you about a very surprising finding
where people lose knowledge of some
kinds of objects in the world but not
others and sort of gave us a new insight
into how our brain organizes knowledge
so Ignacio said modality-specific
inability so we'll talk today about
vision there's no there's a notice in an
audition audition and in touch and so
I'm law focus just on vision
modality-specific these people are fine
if they hold something or hear something
and it's not explained by things like
you don't see so well or you're not
paying attention or you can't speak it
seems to be just that you lose the
ability to recognize by sight what
something is so again a perceptive
agnosia will link it to the right
hemisphere an associate of nausea to the
left hemisphere and let me show you
examples of what these patients do so
here's patients with right hemisphere
damage we're attempting simply to copy
this triangle or copy these things
that's right in front of them they're
copying it and you can see that it's as
if they had almost no appreciation for
what the thing is out there this is a
pretty miserable 3 ok right right in
front of you it's as if the whole thing
weren't Co hearing for anything even the
shape is just a mysterious bundle of
stuff or we can make a multiple choice
with multiple choice we know it's easier
right so all they have to do is cross
out which of these four things looks
like this you know and they pick the
circle here one start the X they pick
the oh right they're really not getting
almost anything about the quality of the
shape they're really not recognizing
what they're looking at or you know
they'll see something you'll see this
but they'll redo this when they get this
seven four one five they won't take the
first interpretation you will they will
come up with some other okay when these
patients copy something they see right
in front of them that elephant you can
see you can label things but it's
pretty bad copy it's not just that
artistry okay it's a bad sense of what
the coherent shape is in front of you
right in front of them and their vision
is basically fine it's just the shape of
it doesn't make any sense not
surprisingly then maybe these patients
also struggle when you make things a
little harder so what letter is this you
can get that you'd have to look a little
bit harder or you would might get that
this is a cow or this is a car these
patients are terrible at those things as
soon as you make it a little bit hard
they're finished they're also bad if
they have damage in the right hemisphere
posterior Lee at what they call an
unusual of you so often we see something
like a stapler from this view we rarely
quite see it this way but if I showed
you this you could probably make it out
it might take you a moment by itself
okay an unusual view of an object that
you see psychologists all canonical view
but just the usual one and what happens
to patients have damaged in the right
posterior cortex they're terrible at
making this unusual perception of a
common object they're also terrible if
they have to see something that's a
little bit challenging again like here's
some hats but with shadows now normally
we don't think about shadows is a big
problem it is for computers that are
meant to see and it is also a big
problem for patients with damage to the
right posterior cortex it's as if they
can't pull out the object from the
shadow it's all one big glob to them
compare that difficulty just getting
basically what's there to patients with
left hemisphere damage who can't
recognize an object so here's a patient
who was shown pictures of a key a pig a
bird a train and was asked to copy them
and the copies are actually excellent I
mean they're much better that I would do
okay they're excellent copies right but
even after the patient has made that
excellent copy of a key he's asked what
is that an official says I don't know
good copy of a pig could be a dog or any
other animal okay that's a dog but
that's it
the bird is kind of interesting he draws
a pretty good bird his copy right but
then he says it could be a beach stump
and when you say that you could see that
but you and I would never you know come
to that conclusion and the train he gets
a little
a wagon or carve some kind it's a larger
being pulled by a smaller Rutland he
vaguely knows it's something but it's
not quite right either right but is he
really gets what it is the shape but
it's it's stripped of meaning it just
doesn't mean anything to him now we're
going to do a video in a moment all
right and I'm gonna show you some videos
today the problem is that these videos
are sort of grainy and there's not like
really high-quality Alan Alda talking on
Scientific American videos of these
patients so the unfortunate thing is in
a visual disorders demonstration it's
almost as if I'm forcing upon you that
same visual disorder okay because you're
looking at it and you go like GI whoo
no wonder if he can't recognize it I
can't recognize it so let me tell you
that in a couple of moments he's gonna
look at a picture of a clarinet okay and
if it were a really good video you would
see it clearly but uh there's just not
many of these around and these patients
are rare who this perfect so I'm gonna
make this dark and we'll see thank you
telling a patient with visual agnosia
and you should be impressed by two
things first he's very verbal he's
speaking he's smart he's a lot of his
brain is working just fine and second I
want to make one you you're gonna see
something kind of interesting which is
you talked about the wear system last
time and sometimes people call the wear
system these assistant for action
because pretty much like where you grab
something where you move there has a lot
to do with the action the physical
action in the world so you're going to
see this man unable to recognize by his
what system what he's looking at but a
little bit of information is gonna sneak
into his aware system and move his hands
okay in a way that you'll see
appropriate so thanks
so so you know it's somebody if you work
of it if you know this idea that well we
only use 10% of our brain I can assure
you this man has you know 95 98 percent
of his brain he can speak he can move he
is he can you know make jokes and you
can curse at the end there a little bit
he can do almost everything that
everybody can do but he cannot identify
what an object is by vision right
because the injury has occurred in the
part of the brain is essential for that
final step of figuring out what you're
looking for so depending on you know
it's a very specific part of the brain
and us but without it the rest of his
brain can't figure out what it's looking
at so his sensation is fine he sees
where it is you know he gets a shape
even roughly he knows like he thought it
was a pen I mean there's something about
the vaguely about the shape his naming
is fine but what it's it's as if again
this idea of the perfect example of what
we call associative ignosi a-- he has
all the shape information seems like you
ought to have all the language
information you have but he can't make
that move from piecing together what
something is to knowing what it means
and if he doesn't know what it means he
can't come up with the name right okay
if he smells that her holds it he says
apple or pie right her pipe okay he
knows the name but if he has to look at
something and then know what it is to
name it right if I show you a piece of
paper and ask you to name it you have to
say okay what is it
then I name it right he can't make that
move and vision to what it is all right
because so much processing has to occur
in your brain to get there even though
it seems instantaneous and trivial to
you it's it's it's instantaneous and
trivial to you because your brain is so
brilliant okay that it accomplishes it
okay so now there are things out there
in the world like animals that occur
naturally that that because they're you
know from an evolutionary tree there's
there are a lot of shapes and there's
things out there that are not living
either that occur like the moon in the
mountain you know out there sitting or
what we call manufactured objects things
like locks pencils motorcycles bulbs
things that humans have made and of
course humans make shapes you know as
they need to
construct things right they're not
constrained by evolutionary forces about
what shape something is we make a shape
as we need it but it was still an
amazing discovery in the 1980s that they
find individual patients who lost the
ability to recognize things in very
specific categories this seemed so much
like old-style silly phrenology that I
can tell you my colleagues sort of made
fun of me when I told them people in my
field we're following finding this ok so
they found patients who could define
and-and-and or by pictures menu factored
objects things like pencils or
typewriters or computers but they
couldn't identify foods or animals and
then they found patients are just the
opposite who could identify foods and
animals but not manufactured objects so
that's really weird
that's as if you know you had organized
in your brain you know the manufactured
section here like in a supermarket and
here's the animal section here's the
fruit section right is it really does
that how our mind is organized like a
supermarket but then there were some
exceptions to these and these are the
exceptions that helped us inform us on
the rule so here's the patients who are
really good at identifying manufactured
things again pencils things like that
bad at foods and animals but now think
about this they were good on body parts
so so how are they good on body parts
when they were bad at foods and animals
body parts are natural right and they
were bad on musical instruments even
though they were good on other
manufactured things like pencils and
computers okay so these were two wrong
things and I'm gonna try to convince you
in a moment that the way we now
understand this is they're good at body
parts because we know how to use our
body and they're bad at musical
instruments because musical instruments
look an awful lot like one another just
like four-legged animals look a lot like
one another okay there's a funny
category for us if we start to divide up
instruments so the problem is not is not
so much one of you know natural versus
unnatural things it's things that we
know through vision versus things that
we know through physical action and use
and here's another example the patients
who are bad
at objects that we use every day like
pencils and stuff like that we're pretty
good and things like billboards and
mountains now only in science fiction
movies do you have creatures big enough
that they're picking up billboards and
throwing it at helicopters from the
military you see that all the time the
big creature and tick it off and they
hurl it right okay so we don't mostly
pick up huge things like mountains and
and large outdoor object like flag poles
right they're not things that we pick up
and use and so the question is so it
seems like the the principle of what's
good or bad is more about how we
experience things through sites or
through physical action so how do we
know things in the world through visual
experience most of us don't get on you
know unless we're alligator wrestlers we
don't get that and you're many that many
animals and most of us you know have
other things that we use all the time
like bulbs and pencils and things like
that and evidence for that was this they
put humans inside a scanner and looked
at their brains as they named either
line drawings or words let's think of
words so it's just words and you're
naming things like elephant and Tiger
does the animal or tools that you use
like pliers or hammer they're visually
they're words but what happens in the
brain is you're naming animals it seems
like you turn on the visual parts of
your brain a lot there's no animal in
there there's not even a picture of an
animal is just a word elephant or the
word cat what happens when you're naming
tools in the left hemisphere we see
turned on an area here that's involved
in visual motion and here in physical
action of moving things in the world all
you're doing is naming words but it's as
if you use this as if the knowledge for
naming them is located in the part of
your brain that uses that information
okay if there's things I recognize by
sight the abstract knowledge about those
things is near my visual system if
there's things I recognize by action
using them the abstract knowledge of
that is located in your brain near parts
of your brain that move things and pick
up things so all of a sudden it makes
sense that you can get separation in
these forms of knowledge because they
reside in your brain near the parts of
the brain that use them
communicate with them so again this idea
that if it's a Simpson like a scissors
your knowledge about scissors will
reside in the parts of the brain that
act upon scissors if it's something like
a bird that you mostly see knowledge
about that bird not just how it looks
but everything will reside in parts of
the brain that are focused on vision so
it's as if your knowledge has moved to
the part of the brain that interacts
with that form of knowledge so let's
talk about faces I mean faces are a huge
thing for us there's at least two huge
things we do with faces we recognize who
people are and what their moods are
right angry happy nice so on so you know
here's one person here's another person
know when I first use this picture he
wasn't a governor he was a movie star
now he's a governor and you have the
problem that you had right a cogniser
people because you have all your
classmates and friends and family
members and a lot of people out there
and not only that you have to recognize
the various expressions they have which
are terribly important for how we
communicate with people moment to moment
all the time so we could say with faces
our big job is who are we looking at
you know friend or foe somebody loved
somebody we don't know because that's
gonna have a huge you know who's that
person and then what's the expression
that we can read from their face that's
a huge part of our lives as social
animals as people who interact with
other people so you saw a film last time
the location was prosopagnosia your book
this time talks about a dr. P he's the
man who mistook his wife for a hat
so he has bigger problems in vision than
simply faces but faces are very
impressive he fails to recognize his
students by their face but he can
recognize them by their voice
modality-specific his general vision is
OK when Oliver Sacks visited him in his
house he tries to reach out his hand and
took hold of his wife's head tried to
lift it off to put it on he had
apparently mistaken his wife for a hat
okay his wife looked as if she was used
to such things right okay you can see
the head and hat they're kind of close
but not if you have typical vision right
he might path the head of water hydrants
and parking meters taking them to the
heads of children all right so you can
see a little bit of there's a little bit
of
logic but it's pretty pretty wrong what
he sees and it's pretty meaningless to
him so let me show you a film of an
example you saw one last time
so so let me say a word about this
imagine that if he couldn't recognize
people right as you walked up it with so
much of how we recognize people we don't
think about this because we instantly
easily recognize those we know well is
by their faces so it was a couple things
usually that's posterior cortical
lesions like in this woman I knew one
man who was a Unitarian minister when
who I worked with actually a couple
blocks away here who went to up to
Dartmouth for the Winter Carnival Cubs
coming back and a small Volkswagen and
turned over on the ice he had a huge
brain injury and became prostatic music
could only recognize his wife by asking
her to wear a yellow bow and her hair
because otherwise he couldn't pick her
out from other people when he went down
the street and passed his brother
completely failed to recognize him then
their brother spoke then he recognized
him and he said and this was his
subjective experience because you wonder
what do these people feel like they see
you know he said that what it felt like
for his brother was you know when
somebody has some bad handwriting and
you can't make it out at all and then
somebody tells you what it is and he go
oh yes you know that's that word and you
know you now you see it he said that's
what it felt like as he heard his
brother's voice and realized it was his
brother okay I mean it's hard to know
how to relate these things but the
ability to recognize a person completely
wiped out in these individuals in the
last six or seven years something else
has been discovered let me say a word
about this which is instead of people
with acute lesions that they got because
of a break their injury is turning out
there's a couple percent of our
population that's really bad at
recognizing faces not the occasional
social embarrassment that many of us
have when we see somebody we know we
should know them or whatever but they're
really really really bad okay there's a
websites you can go to that let you test
yourself because researchers want you to
work with them if you're one of them
okay it's about 1% of the population
there they're really really really bad
so they there was one woman described
that she says they can't watch movies
because all the characters look pretty
much the same to them okay one parent
who has this problem they're really
terrible at faces by formal testing says
that when her kid comes out of school
her own kid if he or is not wearing it
the
clothes that she knows he's wearing she
can't pick him out from the other
children very easily all right
so and these are not people with big
brain injuries these are people have
some some unusual difficulty in
recognizing faces so there's a out there
and you know the classroom this sizer
easily could be one of you it's just we
don't understand what that is it's not a
brain injury it's just something just
like some of us can't carry a tune some
individuals are really terrible at
recognizing faces are really bad so
there's a lot of research into that to
understand what that reflects so let me
tell you what we do understand about the
neural circuitry and the typical brain
for recognizing a face a loved one a
person that you care about so this is
the fusiform gyrus it's the structure in
the back of the brain that extends from
the occipital into the temporal lobes
and that's an anatomical description of
this region within that region there's a
functional area that's that seems very
important for face perception and Nancy
kanwisher who's in our department pretty
much discovered this specific functional
area in the typical human brain and so
she did experiments where she would
present things like faces or objects and
found that especially on the right this
in this picture left is right and right
is left there's a spot in the fusiform
cortex it has this following property
here's faces it turns on here's objects
which have similar properties you know
it has a lot of visual information like
a face but it's not a face this part of
the brain region not so interested faces
objects faces objects so whenever faces
come on this is for by understanding the
first part of your brain that says I'm
looking at a face up until then it's
just treated like other stuff this is
the first part of your brain that
recognizes I'm looking at a face I'm
starting to identify who I'm looking at
and what feelings they might have by
their expression and Nancy and our
colleagues and all kinds of very clever
experiments to show that the properties
of this let me pick one you could say
well it's not about faces that faces are
about humans maybe it's a part of the
brain that tells you when there's a
human around you so they compared faces
versus hands yours hands this part of
the brain is not that interested in
faces hands faces hands you see every
time it moves to faces this part of the
brain gets very strongly engaged it's
very much about faces
by many research studies so let me tell
you a little bit about what we
understand about phases in terms of
developments and things like that
because phases are such a big part of
our lives from the first few moments
were born in fact a colleague of mine
Pavan Sinha did a kind of a
autobiographical research study that was
on the front page of the New York Times
and earned MIT faculty the continuing
names of being Frankenstein faculty
there was a number of faculty right and
what he did kind of very cleverly was he
put on his newborn infants head a little
camera okay so he and he said if I leave
it on there recorded all the time and
apparently there was some debate with
his wife whether he was allowed to do
this but they checked it out it seemed
okay by the by the pediatrician he said
if I had the camera on the on the
infant's head I can see what the the
infants experience is like moment to
moment in the first months of its life
and I can also play with the the video
so that it has roughly speaking the the
properties of the infant's visual system
which is it can't see very far after its
birth they could only see very close by
and not that well over the next several
months we'll talk about slavery cuz it
gets better and better at seeing at a
distance okay so here's the infant
sitting and in his or her crib and this
video makes incredibly clear beautifully
a fascinatingly clear something that I
never thought of until until Pavan to
the study
this is examination which is so the
infant sitting there I can't move very
much can't go very many places right as
a newborn infant so what is it see what
gets close enough to it to be visible to
the infant people's faces okay because
the all the other cute things in the
nursery all the other things are out
there they're they're too far or too
blurry for the infant to process almost
at all almost the only thing that
happens is you know the parent the
grandparent the siblings the friends
that come over and go what a cute baby
you know baby bbbbbb the face comes in
okay okay all right
person's done gone now you're just
sitting in a Wordle blur here comes
another face okay all right so besides
certain issues related to perhaps the
feeding the only thing the infant sees
our faces all right all the time so it's
that very important a social cue of who
its interacting on what's out there
almost the only one available to it so
psychologists have been
known for some time that if you show a
very young infants a face versus
something like an object like a car or
anything like that they're much more
interested in faces okay if you put them
next to each other where the infant can
see them and they've been saying well
there's a brain born to process faces
and it might be and I'll show you
evidence to suggest in some general
sense it is what is that infants you
know brain drawn to what is it find
fascinating to learn about in the world
and so they noticed that well one thing
about a face is is is in terms of
features eyes nose mouth top-heavy right
to eye
because we have two eyes and everything
else is one and one the nose in the
mouth
so here's you can move the features like
this and it turns out not only are
infant's more interested in this kind of
face than this and they know that
because they'll put the two up and
they'll measure how long the infant
looks at one versus the other which is
interesting but in the infant fix this
one but get a load of this the infant
also picks this one versus this this one
versus this and this one versus this now
these look very little like a face right
but they're top-heavy okay it's as if
maybe the infant's brain to start with
maybe looks for some interesting
top-heavy things and that pulls it into
the world of faces here's some more
experiments like that so here's a face
you know upside down right side up baby
looks more at this kind of face okay you
could say well that's a normal face but
it's also top-heavy right then they make
these kind of scary-looking faces you
know they're not
and now the baby even though these are
nothing like a face the baby ever sees
it still likes this one because it's
top-heavy now how about this one this is
like a face they see this is a really
weird face right they'll never see a
face like this except in this experiment
top-heavy top-heavy and now the infant
looks at both of them with equal
interest and delight right so that's a
very clever experiment to suggest that
the infant's mind
is looking for top-heavy things and you
could say is it really top-heavy or is
that what the infant's mind and brain
can look for and it goes with faces and
that was in evolution pick that you know
we have it's hard to know how to think
about these things but it looks like the
top heaviness draws an infant
be fascinated by faces right so and
luckily you know you don't get many
faces like this to confuse you all right
in the real world okay another thing
that people study a lot about faces is
this so that that it's incredibly they
use that word configural that the
relations among the parts are more
important than the parts themselves so I
need a volunteer in their seat and this
is gonna be really easy if you know the
alphabet you have to put up your hand
and help me out okay thank you very much
I'm going to scribe to a letter by its
features okay
it has a big blind at the top and in the
middle there's a line that goes down to
the bottom what's the letter
awesome okay featural description now
I'm gonna describe to you a super mu
famous movie star and this person has
two eyes to the left and to the right
and nose right below that and a mouth
right below that and who is it Angelina
Jolie right okay okay so what's my point
here is the stuff that helps us in many
things like the letters thank you that
was excellent okay you know we can
describe those by the parts and the
parts pretty much define the whole
that's not true for faces really is the
precise relations between eyes and nose
and mouth to tell us and there's an
experiment that shows us in a very
empirical direct way so they would show
people a face like this with a
particular nose or a house like this
with a particular door and then they
would test your memory for that nose or
that door by itself as features or with
the whole face or a whole house present
okay and here's what happens for
people's performance the nose by itself
the door by itself the nose when you see
the whole picture which could be his
nose it could be another nose here's the
door it could be that door or a
different door and here's what happens
in performance if it's houses people
were good for doors about the same
whether they identified the door by
itself or the door in the context of the
house if it's noses they were a lot
better off seeing the entire face as if
how we analyze even the parts of a face
are really integrated immediately into
the other aspects of the face they don't
stand alone they're a part of a context
all interacting together now
here's something pretty striking and
interesting and we'll talk about some
people's social implications of this at
the end of the lecture so you can you
the way you can't ask infants many
things but you can look at record their
behavior and learn some things about
what their minds are representing and
thinking and here's how they test an
infant I'd say six months of age can't
talk can't walk can't be instructed to
push buttons or fill out surveys okay
how do they get inside the mind of what
an infant knows what the do is to show a
face and pretend they show this face all
by itself infant looks for a little bit
face disappears and then they see the
face they just saw and a new face and
infants who saw this face a few moments
ago will spend more time looking at the
new face than the old face you can track
where their eyes are and that's the
evidence they remember the face they saw
before because they selectively spend
more time on the new face and also
they're hungry to look at the new face
it's like I've seen this face been there
done that okay
new face check out this person right if
you test them at six months they'll have
a preference you know for the face the
new face but if you show them two
different monkeys and this might feel
hard for you to tell these apart if you
show them two different monkeys they'll
behave the same with monkey faces as
they do with human faces they'll prefer
the novel face which shows you they
remember what face they saw before and
want to look at the new face and at six
months it's the same for humans and
monkeys now at nine months no forget
most of these people are interacting a
lot with adults and siblings and
caretakers right not many of them are
hanging out with monkeys they start to
get much more accurate for human faces
the experience they have with human
faces starts to make them much better at
that at Birth faces from one species are
as good as another but with practice and
experience they become human face
specialist and to become much better at
that so it's not in our genes to be
awesome at human faces but something
about faces and then a lot depends on
what we see and we grow that part of our
mind and brain so here's a remarkable
experiment that you couldn't do with
people that was done with infant monkeys
these monkeys after they were
were given no exposure to faces
depending on the monkey for six to 24
months that's not quite completely true
because after birth they saw their some
faces that you couldn't start this
experiment at the first moment of birth
but as soon as they could from birth for
6 to 24 months so when they were being
fed this is what they saw they were
given an interesting environment to see
lots of stuff and they would live in
something like this so they could not
see another monkey they could not see a
human they never saw a face except for
the first moments of birth then they you
know allowed them before they saw any
living face on a monkey or a human they
would do these kinds of experiments that
you just heard with infants and they
would show that these monkeys would
preferentially look at faces both human
faces and monkeys and they no preference
between them they would always go for a
face compared to an object a monkey face
or a human face and they could do this
kinds of discrimination the first moment
before they had ever except for whatever
happens right at Birth scene 1 so they
never practiced on anything because they
had not been allowed to see a face but
the first moment before they saw any
living face they already had this
preference for faces for both humans and
monkeys all right as if it's in our
genes to be drawn to faces and what the
mechanism is a top-heavy something else
you know you don't quite know but it's
in our brain to go for faces so they're
so important for us then some monkeys
hung around people and some monkeys were
hung around monkeys ok and what happened
is really quite striking they got better
at the species they hung around so if
you did these kinds of tests the monkeys
who hung around monkeys got better and
better at monkeys and monkeys that hung
around people got better and better at
people all right so what does that mean
that means it looks like there's a
genetic preparation the first face that
they see with the slight asterisks at
the moment of birth they're already
preferring faces the very first one they
see even though they've gone 6 months to
two years without seeing any face at all
and then they get better selectively on
the species they're exposed to so
there's a genetic preparation and then
kind of a sensitive period where you
build up a representation of the speed
she's that you're living with so let me
slide there for a moment or now writing
so you know as long as there's been
mammals as long as there's been people
you know we've been born to things
around us with faces and interacting
with people
well faces right okay so that's deep in
our evolutionary history not deep in our
evolutionary history is writing and
reading the first visual language of any
kind is about you know four thousand
years ago not until the Gutenberg Bible
and subsequent and that's about six
hundred years ago was there you know to
the large numbers of people read so
unlike faces and objects which have been
around forever not only for us but for
other species writing and reading have
been around only for a few hundred years
our brains are not evolved to be reading
brains it's just an unbelievably
powerful cultural invention and people
can read fast a typical reader can do
this this is kind of amazing I mean if
you didn't know anything with most of us
know somewhere between 50,000 and
100,000 words okay we don't know all of
them well we can't spell all of them
correctly but we kind of can get them if
we see them and if we show you one word
in 50 thousandths of a second you can
recognize which word you saw it's kind
of amazing people read about 200 to 250
words per minute a typical reader
cruising along when they're focused
these things can be measured relatively
simply here's one that's a little
trickier but let me tell you again it
shows you how experiments I think can
tell us something we could not have
guessed without the experiment about how
you read every moment you've read
throughout your life okay so I'm gonna
tell you now that you read about 12
letters at a time and then you move your
eyes wherever you're reading a book on
the computer you'll read about 12
letters that's where you're fixated
those will only be visible to you and
then you'll move your eyes to get the
next set of letters you need to read
okay now you go know there's text there
I'm looking I'll give you I move my eyes
but what really happening let me show
you how blind you are to everything but
12 letters at a time so here's the
experiment for McConkey and Rainer and
many people have found this since they
tracked people's eye movements you could
have machine that tracks where your eyes
are fixated where you're looking
every time you moved what they did is
they took the text that was written
across a monitor
they kept about 12 letters where you're
looking and they made everything else on
the monitor X's okay you don't know this
you're just reading okay so you're
reading people of this is where your
eyes are the computer makes everything
else in X you move your eyes now this
becomes X's and these are X's you move
your eyes
these become X's you move your eyes
these become X's does that make sense
every time you move where you land they
give you the words and letters but
everything to the left and right are all
X's and this downing thing is nobody
ever says hey why are there all the X's
right because when you're reading
unbeknownst to you you only see it with
good acuity 12 letters at a time and
everything else you don't you barely
notice it's there you notice something
is there if there's nothing there you
would notice it but your mind is not
really seeing it at all okay and so
people have tried to represent this this
when you read it something like this
okay where you look in your phobia or
your high acuity you see about 12
letters everything else is like this and
that's why if I flip it to X's you don't
even notice cuz it's all pretty crummy
how you see it you notice something is
there but it's pretty crummy is that
okay now you could say I don't believe
it but people have done this experiment
over over again and when they flip
everything to access to the left and
right of about 12 letters looking at
people just don't know because they
don't really see it as they read anyway
that makes sense twelve letters at a
time so again we're trying to understand
some of these things in regards to
difficulties people have so it turns out
there's a part of the brain that's also
involved in reading called where if you
have damaged you get what's called a
word blindness so these are adults who
are good readers no problem in reading
they get a stroke in the left visual
cortex around here the most famous
original case in 1887 all of a sudden
one day after a headache
he could heat this man was unable to
read his vision was otherwise perfectly
good he could hear words and speak words
he could see numbers he could write down
words his writing was kind of
low and laborious okay and it wasn't
typical writing but then you could show
him a few moments later of what he had
written and he would not be able to read
it aloud okay so here's a pathway that's
where stuff out there in the world
envision meets how we read
amazing now it turns out just like
there's a spot in your brain that's the
first moment where something you see is
a face there's a part that showed here
in in red that's near that it's bigger
in the left hemisphere that the language
hemisphere that's pretty specifically
specific for words compared to other
things and so we end up with a picture
like this of relatively specific areas
in the back of our brain that are highly
specialized for recognizing where things
are I didn't talk too much about that
but there's tech area faces words and
objects and if you have damage to any of
these pathways for whatever reason the
rest of our brain can't compensate and
it's all a big mystery Who am I looking
at what word am I looking at what object
do I see now you might imagine that for
things like faces or locations we've had
evolutionary pressure forever to be good
at that where are we who are we with
whereas things like words or nonsense
words and letters or chairs which are a
recent cultural invention our brains are
not genetically predisposed to the
specific category so here's a very
clever study from Ted Polk at Michigan
so we took twins and we'll talk more
about this and but the way people try to
get it until we know the real genes
involved in things they'll compare twins
who are identical twins with the
identical genes and twins who are
so-called fraternal twins right who are
born to the same family but don't have
the identical genes and to the extent
the identical twins are more similar to
each other than the fraternal twins
that's a suggestion there's genetic
influences on whatever you're looking at
so what they did is they had these
people look at faces places letter
strings and shares and they calculated
how similar was one twin to another okay
either identically genetic or not and
what they found was that for the faces
and the house and the places there was
much more similarity significantly more
similarity between identical twins than
fraternal twins that's the genetic
predisposition in some way of how you
will see a face or know where you are if
they compared reading nonsense words
letter strings or chairs that two kinds
of twins where of just the same
it's as if there's no genetic
predisposition in you to know where in
your brain you're gonna process words or
chairs but that makes sense because you
know a couple thousand years ago there
were no words okay and a few more
thousand years and that there were no
chairs right so that's not you we don't
have the genes for recent inventions in
the world but our brain is brilliant and
becoming good at things like reading as
we invent them okay for the last part of
the talk I want to talk about face
recognition so all of us know that when
we learned to read it was a pretty big
deal so a while ago yeah if you're a
typical reader you're past it if you're
struggling reader that can be a
persistent problem but you got through
it and you're a reader none of us went
to third grade and said today is the day
that we study faces right okay all right
and your parents are going I hope you're
good at faces because we really want you
go to MIT someday you know yeah this is
a moment to get ready for the face SAT
but what I'm going to show you is an in
fact through experience you're educated
for faces and there's some social
consequences for the faces you're not
educated on the on average so let's talk
about that so one way we see faces is we
see faces that are right-side up right
okay overwhelmingly so I'm going to show
you this upside down face I'm gonna
reverse it and that's what it is
okay it's gruesome right but can you
tell that it's gonna when I when that
turns it's going to be this so the way
that we interpret the weirdness of face
inversion the fact that we process
upside down faces so badly okay we don't
have a hint of what's really there it's
because we didn't practice on them it's
as if I gave you a test in a language
that you never spoke or read well you
can do badly right so that shows you
that face thing is not it's not so
experience dependent it's because you
see upright faces you get good at
upright faces all we have to do is turn
it upside down and all the knowledge and
skill you have it's as if I would tested
you in a different language it's that
specific here's another example side by
side looks pretty similar but that's
what you're really seeing right it's I
mean you know if you it's unbelievable
right okay you turn your head to believe
me if in case you're suspicious or yeah
okay no this is
so you know we're so bad at upside down
faces because we don't practice on them
okay so so what will you're good at in
faces is so much dependent on what we
practice now you may recognize this
person or not
okay these are less dramatic but very
now people don't become as good as they
get at faces until about age 16 we don't
consciously practice it but the social
experience we have is practicing
practicing practicing how you perceive a
face and one fun study from the Susan
Kerry now at Harvard is she took dog
show judges now I don't know too much
about dog show some of you might know
something but a little bit what I know
is this sort of like in sports you have
judges who work their way up a ladder of
experience and reputation okay so in
sports things you know you have the
local judges and the really good ones
become the ones for the bigger leagues
and the big ones get to go to the Super
Bowl of the World Series who are really
skilled and thought to be excellent
right doctor so judges similarly start
locally that once it seemed pretty good
and persistent at it you know then
become the state judge show then they go
to the big one in New York so they did
this face inversion experiments on dog
show judges people who are just
beginning to be a dog show judge people
who've done it for a while people didn't
for a lot of years and they asked when
do you get so much better at a
right-side up dog face that an upside
down dog face now you know most people
are about the same to start with right
because we're not that good at dog faces
well no it mean you might know got a dog
or two but you don't know hundreds of
dogs it took eight years for dog show
judges and they were dog enthusiasts you
know for many years before they became a
dog show judge eight years of seeing
many many dogs at dog show competitions
to develop the upright face expertise
that we all have for faces as adults so
for an adult you have to practice eight
years to get this kind of expertise all
right so it's you can't just do it by
cramming it's practice practice practice
in the most brutal fundamental sense
now let's say one last thing about this
and go to last topic the other thing is
that we understand also and we've
mentioned this before about say one more
time that that imagination and
perception use the same neural territory
in your mind
so here's a study from Nancy kanwisher
again here's a part of the brain that
responds to faces seeing a face seeing a
house seeing a face seeing a house now
imagining a face imagining a house
imagining a face imagining in a house so
the preceding one drives the brain more
strongly than imagining it but when you
imagine in a face you seem to use the
same brain Network as when you see it
it's just not as a vivid and powerful
all right so perception is the stuff
literally in your mind of imagination
you can imagine things because you've
seen them before literally in your brain
is the same part of the brain so the
last topic I want to talk about is a
sensitive and difficult one so I'm going
to do it right I hope but one that's a
practical one and a consequence we
believe of the fact that you're good at
faces that you practice so we're going
to talk about in this in these studies
people perceiving faces of European
Americans or white Americans or African
Americans and there's a huge amount of
research that shows the following that
whatever racial group you see a lot of
you're pretty good at remembering those
face and whatever group you see less
you're far worse okay
we interpret this as a consequence of
the practice that you have but social
psychologists worry it has a second
consequence so let me tell you the
practice story so we did a study this is
this is from us but it's very similar to
other people in terms of the conclusion
there's a little bit early like a
thousand of these studies that show that
people are superior recognizing in an
experiment faces from their own group
than from other groups and here
experiment that was done with Stanford
students up we look in their mind and
then in their brain so these are
Stanford students just some years ago
maybe a lot like you in many ways and
there were they saw some faces and then
they got a memory test
this is the performance on the memory
test so we we had both European American
and African American faces that they
viewed and the participants in the
research were both African American and
European American okay so there were
white faces white subjects black faces
black subjects and what you can see is
this higher the bar the better the
memory in both groups they're better in
performance at remembering faces from
their own group right but there's more
to it than that if you look at the these
bars these are the memory for the white
faces and it's about the same and that's
say two groups and look at the big
difference for the african-american
faces so two things are happening here
one of them is their superior memory
from faces from your own group and the
second story is that for what we believe
from other research as well as this that
if you're a minority group
you're still pretty good at the majority
faces if you're a majority group you're
not so good at the minority faces so
these are European Americans Stanford
students and look how miserable their
memory is for this african-american
faces this is a difficult topic for us
because in part because race is a
different topic for good reasons but
it's social psychologists worry but the
lack of practice that many of us have on
other groups growing up at home in our
community in schools and it varies for
people but on average makes us less able
to individuate in our memory one person
from another in other groups and that's
exaggerated this is a simple objective
recognition of faces but it could
certainly support consideration of other
groups as if they were all the same
because they look all the same so I
remember I had an african-american
colleague at Stanford and he was a Dean
and he went to China with a Nobel
laureate who's now the secretary of
energy in the Obama administration and
Steve chewing and of course Nobel
laureates are pretty big deals right
Dean was you know went to this noble
Lord all the time as we were as they
were meeting Stanford donors and other
things right
he said that they got on the plane they
went to China the two of them and he
went into a reception and he knew Steve
Chu he was in there the African American
Dean said I could not pick him out for
my life when I saw him now not with a
people other people I know but with a
500 other Chinese people in a large
reception all right so it's not about
bad attitudes in this case it's just
literally the experience you have and in
the brain this this part this FFA
responds more to groups from your own on
average from your own racial group than
the other racial group and we think
that's promoting the ease with which you
identify individuals in your group and
the difficulty with which were you can
undefined individuals another group and
so we have strong reason to think that
this is all about this particular
phenomenon about your experience so let
me tell you why one thing is we know
that this is not present at Birth people
have done these kinds of experiments
with infants these racial biases and
what kinds of faces we can remember are
not present at birth so they're not in
our genes they're from our experience
but they are present by three months but
by then you've seen a lot of people in
your family and the kind of experiment
that's very telling for this is a study
where they were Korean children there
were three to nine years old they were
adopted by European Caucasian families
okay so in this sense a cross-racial
adoption and then they tested their
memory for faces and for these Korean
children adopted by European Caucasian
families they had better memory for the
Caucasian faces because that's who they
saw around them all the time and they
were just like their French peers who
also saw Caucasian faces all the time
and the office of the findings that
you've got with Korean children in South
Korea so it's you know the inversion one
is kind of funny
amazing right the the fact that we can
struggle to individuate in memory one
african-american from another or one
asian-american from another or one
Caucasian American from another
depending on the environment that we
grew up in
exposed to that could be you know
facilitating stereotyping and lack of
individuation of people in other groups
so the very last thing one do and this
is just a couple minutes is talk about
expression
faces and I'll come back to this in
detail before I would just wanna give
you one last example of recognition of a
in the amygdala and fear so we'll come
back to this in some detail later on but
the motion researchers have argued that
there's about six basic emotions that
people around the world transmit with
their facial expressions happiness
sadness fear anger surprise and disgust
you can show these pictures to people
around the world and there'll be to some
degree a consensus about what they are
universal expressions of feelings
transmitted by facial expressions now
let's talk about fear faces I'll just
talk about fear today
and we'll talk about the amygdala so we
have one on the left and when the rights
a very small structured almond-shaped
one in your inside each of your temporal
lobes are right next to the hippocampus
so that's a view from the side of where
that's located one on the left and one
on the right and we know from a lot of
animal research and I'll come back to
this again the amygdala is essential for
learned fear for learned fear so here's
an experiment that shows you that okay
one thing that my snow is cats are bad
news okay it's survival what they did in
this experiment is they anesthetize the
cat that's why the Catholics glassy-eyed
obviously the experiment would end too
quickly for further for the mouse of the
mouse had to you know come out and play
with a cat the experiment would be
brutal and ugly and over too quickly
right but it but if the cat is the cat
is breathing the cat's eyes are opens
and that's the facts we can't move now
you a typical rat will still or Mouse
serve most well typically still avoid
the cat it's not worth figuring out
exactly what's going on with that
cat-like eye they're taking me out right
it's just I'll just go that way right so
this but not not them at the mouse who
has the amygdala removed it doesn't it's
not fearful of what it ought to be
fearful of anymore okay
even survival I mean what we believed
the most important role of fear is not
fear of SATs or midterms
we live in that world okay it's fear of
what can injure you and kill you
those are the things to learn be fearful
look and kill you be fearful of what can
injure you
without the amygdala you lose that fear
but here's the other last this is my
last amazing thing there are humans who
have injuries selectively to the
amygdala very few but there's a few and
not only do they have some problems with
fear learning but they can't recognize
fearful facial expressions anymore
so here's a if they ask them to say what
is this without the word present they're
very bad at telling you that's a fearful
face they can recognize all the other
expressions pretty well but not the
fearful ones and this patient also has
the good at faces they're not posed a
big notice if they're fine to faces they
recognize your family but they can't
recognize fearful expressions
selectively and when they draw it this
is actually very good drawing happy sad
surprised disgusted angry when she's
asked to draw a fearful facial
expression this patient draws this a
baby being afraid she understands the
concept but it's not only that she can't
recognize it she can't imagine what a
fearful face looks like and we saw this
over and over again and now specifically
that and there's one last message in
this somehow our knowledge about what a
fearful face looks like we're not scared
of this you don't look at this go oh my
gosh I can't believe he showed that in
class you know I'll never sleep for 48
hours good right that's not what what
that's a social signal for somebody
telling you well there's something
terrible happening here look around you
we better run right there's social
signal and the part of your brain that
learns to what looking kill you also is
where the knowledge is stored to
recognize a social signal about
something that could be very dangerous
the same idea that we put our knowledge
in the parts of their brain that act
upon the world
you